こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです！
みなさんLINE使ってますか？
そしてLINEスタンプどんなの使ってますか？
まあほんとLINEスタンプってもう
ほんとにいろんな種類があると思うんですけども
僕のイチオシは昔動画でも紹介した
【はじめ沈黙】
名前忘れたな
謎の犬
謎の犬っていうスタンプがあります
ちょっと軽くおさらいしましょう
ｵｵｩ   ｳｳﾝ
ﾝ?   ｳｳｰﾝ
ｳｰﾝ   ﾝｰｰ   ｱｧ!
ｳｰﾝ   ﾌｰﾝ   ﾝﾝ
ﾝｰｰ   ｳｰｰﾝ   ｱｧｰ
ｳｰﾝ   ﾌｩｰﾝ
ｱｯ!
あっ…
おい、やめろやめろ…
やばいやばい！
まさき落ち着け！
やばいやばい暴れてる！
ｱｧ
おいおい！まさき落ち着け！
ﾝｰ   ﾌｰｰﾝ   ﾝﾝｰ
ﾝｰ   ｳｩｰｰ   ﾊｰｰ   ﾊｧｰ
ｳｩｰ   ﾝﾝｰ   ｳｳｰ
ｳｰ   ﾝｰ   ﾝﾌ
ﾝｰ   ｵｰｰ  ﾝﾝｰ
ていう感じでですね
あの、犬のスタンプが
いや、バカバカバカ…
ていう感じでですね
犬のスタンプがあります
そしてなんと…！
犬のスタンプ、第二弾が出ました！
（はじめ拍手）
えらくはねえわ
とりあえずちょっと第二弾
どんなのか見ていきましょう
(ﾜｫｰｰﾝ)
ワンちゃんの体の等身が
ちょっとおかしいんですけど
まあちょっとカラオケを歌ってますね
(ｳｩｰｰﾝ)
ロウソクを見て落ち着いてるワンちゃん
(ﾜﾝ)
魔法使いのワンちゃん
髪の毛生えたワンちゃん
(ﾜｳ)
投げキッスしてるワンちゃん
(ｳｰ)
ラッパ吹くワンちゃん
(ｳｰﾝ)
ごはん食べるワンちゃん
(ﾝﾌｰ)
食べた後のワンちゃん
なんとも言えない表情してますね
(ﾜﾝ)
歯丸出しワンちゃん
敬礼ワンちゃん
(ﾜﾝ)
Drivingワンちゃん
(ﾝﾝ)
なんか覗いてるワンちゃん
(ﾜｳ)
クラッカー出て喜ぶワンちゃん
(ﾜﾝ)
めちゃくちゃ堅そうなフランスパンを
食べるワンちゃん
(ﾜｰﾝ)
そしてこれ！
カードゲームをやってるワンちゃん
なんかカードゲームつったら
なんか見覚えある気がするんだよなあ
誰かなあ？
誰かに似てんだよなあ
(ﾜﾝ)
喜ぶワンちゃん
運動するワンちゃん
(ﾜｰﾝ)
ラジコン飛ばすワンちゃん
あれ？
なんか最近…
なんかラジコンてか
なんかドローンの免許取った
なんかドローンの免許取ったYouTuberいた
ような気がするんだけど誰だったかなあ
(ﾜｰﾝ)
さよならワンちゃん
(ﾜｵｰﾝ)
宇宙に行くワンちゃん
(ﾜﾝ)
修業するワンちゃん
(ﾜｳ)
文字書くワンちゃん
(ﾜﾝ)
描かれたワンちゃん
もう誰だよ
(ﾜﾝ)
ドクターワンちゃん
あれ？
んーどこかで白衣着て
実験動画撮ってたYouTuberがいた気がするなあ
誰だったっかなあ
(ﾜﾝ)
工事現場ワンちゃん
(ﾜｳﾜｳ)
ムキムキワンちゃん
(ﾜｵｰﾝ)
お茶入れてるワンちゃん
(ﾜｵｰﾝ!)
くさーい！ワンちゃん
(ﾜﾝﾜﾝ!)
超ズームレンズワンちゃん
(ﾜｰﾝ)
バレーボールワンちゃん
(ﾜｰﾝ!)
野球ワンちゃん
(ﾜｰｰﾝ!)
スプレーワンちゃん
(ﾜﾝ)
忍者ワンちゃん
(ﾜﾝﾜﾝ!)
シャカシャカワンちゃん
(ﾜｰﾝ)
商品紹介ワンちゃん
はっ…
あれ？
なんかカメラを自分に向けて
商品紹介するなんか職業みたいなのが
あった気がすんだけど誰だったかなあ
(ﾜﾝ!)
動画編集ワンちゃん！
あれ？
動画編集する職業みたいなのが
あった気がするんだけど誰だったかなあ
(ﾜｵｰﾝ)
おやすみワンちゃん
(ﾜﾝﾜﾝﾜﾝ)
歯磨きワンちゃん
ふっww
(ﾜｳ)
誰ですか
(ﾜﾝ)ハンドスピナーワンちゃん
あれ？
どっかでなん…
ハンドスピナーやけに回してた
YouTuberいたような気がするなあ
誰だったかなあ
ちょっとほんと使い道がよく分かんない
スタンプだらけなんですけど
はいというわけで第二弾のワンちゃんスタンプ
またまたマニアックなやつが多いんですけども
謎の犬のアカウント
Twitterで昔現れたんですけども
ちょっとあの人にこの新しいスタンプがでたよ
っていうのをちょっと
教えてあげようかなって思います
では
はいでは早速ワンちゃんと喋っていきましょう
とりあえずね、この子が新しいスタンプ出てるのか
知ってるかどうかまたわかんないんで
はい、というわけで早速スタンプ送ってみました
さあ、謎の犬はどういう反応をするでしょうか
【はじめ待機】
めっちゃ反応悩んどるやん
「知ってます。イケ犬そのものですね！」
「かっこよすぎるわん」
情報が早いな
もう知ってんのか
ちょっとあんまりイケメンじゃなかった
スタンプもあったんで
これはどうだったのかなあ
てか最近お犬さん何してんだろうなあ
やば、フォロワー13570人もいるじゃん！
なに最近、ピィィィィって言ってんのあなた
この子それなりに更新してるんすよね
よく飽きねえな
「なんだかんだU-FES行きたかった」って言ってたし
すげえな、なんかちゃんと定期的に
3日おきぐらいに「わんわん」って言ってますね
「バウバウバウバウバウバウ」
「ワンワンワンワンワンワンワン」
「わおーん」
「わんわん」
「わんわんわん」
ん？？
お、「お前名前変えたってわかってるからな」
「今度こそツイ消しすんじゃねぇぞ」
喧嘩しとるやないかい！
どうした、 喧嘩しとるやんけ！
あら、帰ってこなくなったよ
帰ってこなくなっちゃった！
ぶさかわ…だって
ちょっとこのワンちゃん的に
どれが一番好きか聞いてみましょう
僕個人的には完全にこのデュエルしてます
みたいなのが一番好きなんすよね
おおお
おおお！
なるほどこれがおすすめらしいですね
後姿のやつだ
謎の犬もちゃんとなんかスタンプの
このちょっと感動しました
すごいな、よく飽きずにやってんな
ちょっと最近元気かだけ聞いてみよう
謎の犬元気だったらいいなあ(あくび)
おお！びっくりした！
ふざけんじゃねえぞ！ww
元気かよかったよかった
最近の趣味はなんですか
最近の趣味は音楽らしいですね
おー音楽が最近好きなんですね
なんか最近ワンちゃんは
音楽にハマってるみたいですね
じゃあ最後に視聴者さんに何か一言！
お、消えた！
なにか言おうとしてる…
"See you next time!!"
"Bee new(美乳) next time!! "
【ED】
ふっww「一本取られました」ってなんだよ